imagine a university that spans the
globe with students from more than a
hundred countries and engaged alumni
parents and friends virtually everywhere
Carnegie Mellon is that University a
decade ago Carnegie Mellon established
its first satellite location outside
Pittsburgh in Silicon Valley today
students can earn a Carnegie Mellon
degree in more than a dozen countries
around the world from this growth CMU
gains tuition cultural literacy and
diversity expanded networking
opportunities new venture partners and
reputational strength in the last decade
the number of alumni groups has more
than doubled
groups also have begun to evolve beyond
formal chapters in major metropolitan
areas the university's investment in
people and technology has resulted in
informal networks and grassroots efforts
around a common profession avocation or
cause today's global communication
environment makes connections easier
more flexible and more organic the
number of alumni parents and friends who
in some way volunteer time on Carnegie
Mellon's behalf identifying talent and
listing influential friends and
organizing resources has increased
significantly from roughly 2000 in 2005
to more than 5,000 today
you